la parole à monsieur michel heinrich
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
l'article 58 du projet de loi de
finances pour 2016 vise à mettre en
oeuvre la réforme de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement du bloc communal afin
de réduire les écarts de dotation par
habitant que le gouvernement juge
injustifiées ou souhaitait introduire
une dotation forfaitaire de 75 euros par
habitant pour toutes les communes
l'histoire de la dgf est certes
compliqué mais l'origine des différences
de dgf n'est pas toujours injustifiées
compte tenu du poids de certaines
charges comme les charges de centralité
où les charges touristique que vous
envisagez de supprimer qui ne seront que
très partiellement compensé les
évaluations et études d'impact sont
étrangement absente de votre projet de
refonte de la dgf
quel impact peut-on tirer de cette
réforme pour les villes en 2016 2017
2018 voire 2025 quels sont les strates
gagnante est celle qui seront perdantes
quels sont les résultats pour les
collectivités en 2016
or mécanisme de stabilisation autant de
questions posées et qui n'ont pour le
moment aucune réponse
les effets de cette réforme qui vont se
cumuler avec le mécanisme de
contribution des collectivités locales
au redressement des finances publiques
montrent avoir au final d impact
extrêmement négatif pour les communes de
plus de 15000 habitants dont la dotation
forfaitaire comme la pression fiscale
est historiquement plus importante qu'en
milieu rural
par ailleurs l'extension en cours du
périmètre des intercoms pose un problème
de calendrier de cette réforme puisque
la stabilisation des périmètres ne sera
effective qu'en 2017 voire 2018 dans ces
conditions monsieur le premier ministre
ne serait-il pas nécessaire et
raisonnable comme le souhaitent les
maires de toutes sensibilités politiques
les maires de villes que cette réforme
soit remise à 2017 et que l'on mette à
profit l'année 2016 pour réaliser de
réels simulation et pour mener une âpre
une étude approfondie
avec tout le secteur du bloc communal
d'état chargé de la réforme territoriale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député quel est le constat la dgf est
devenue illisible et profondément
injuste
elle est illisible parce que elle est le
résultat d'une sédimentation accumulées
depuis des années de notation qui ont
été supprimées et qui sont compensées
donc illisibilité total plus personne ne
s'y retrouve même le plus grand
spécialiste des finances locales
deuxièmement elle est devenue très
injuste au lieu de corriger les
inégalités entre les collectivités
locales notamment les communes elles
aggravent les inégalités entre communes
d'une même strate à potentiel fiscal
équivalent à richesse équivalente à
population équivalente
les écarts vont du simple au double du
simple au double messieurs le député
donc le constat est unanime il fait
l'objet du rapport de madame christine
pires bonne et du sénateur regretté jean
germain
ce constat est unanime il faut réformer
la dgf qui dans cet hémicycle peut nier
qu'il faille réformer la dgf
il faut la réformer quelle réforme une
réforme pour plus de clarté et plus de
justice plus de clarté ce sont trois
dotation une dotation forfaitaire de
base la même en euros par habitant la
même pour toutes les communes de france
une dotation de centralité pour les
communes qui subissent des charges de
centralité et une dotation de ruralité
pour les communes rurales
c'est assez pour la clarté pour la
justice nous allons renforcer la
péréquation
la dotation de solidarité urbaine et la
dotation de solidarité rurale
les premières simulations monsieur le
député laisse apparaître que deux tiers
des communes seraient bénéficiaires de
cette réforme deux tiers des communes
représentant 65% de la population de la
même façon que les premières simulations
laisse apparaître que 72% des opci les
intercommunalités serait bénéficiaire de
cette réforme représentant 74 % de la
population dans ces conditions nous
devrons la réussir ensemble cette
réforme
le gouvernement sera les coûts du
parlement pour l'améliorer l'amendé
l'enrichir car les élus attendent cette
réforme de justice et de solidarité
merci monsieur le ministre pour l'europe
l'est républicain